hi I'm Erik Bosse and x-men Dark Phoenix
is a movie that is still happening even
if it's marketing team decides the best
way to promote this movie is to release
trailers in the middle of the damn night
and blatantly reveal the death of a main
character sure look I gotta say despite
this movie's repeated release delays
like it's now coming out June 7th
instead of a couple weeks ago and the
x-men's likely reboot when Fox and
Marvel officially merged and how easy it
is to forget that the x-men movie
universe even exists outside of Deadpool
like it didn't all get wiped away during
one of those many time-travel rewrites
despite all that after this trailer
I think Dark Phoenix is a good chance to
be a surprise it I know I'm just liking
what I'm seeing
so I'm gonna break down this trailer
shot-for-shot for all the details that
you might have overlooked it's morning
in case they accidentally predicted
anything to right and I ruin your life
let's get started look at me
focus on my voice okay the trailer opens
quite dramatically with Jean Grey
sitting alone in the rain sobbing to
some other presence inside herself poor
Sophie Turner she just can't get a role
that gets her out of the elements Dark
Phoenix is being adapted from the Dark
Phoenix saga of the x-men comics one of
the most popular storylines from that
whole franchise you may remember the
attempt to adapt it in x3 The Last Stand
yes actually this Dark Phoenix movie
looks like it's trying to be kind of a
do-over of that movie many of the story
beats and set pieces look pretty similar
and both movies are produced by longtime
x-men producer Simon Kinberg who is
directing this one essentially Jean Grey
it's an omega-level mutant among the
most powerful of all mutants she has
telepathy and telekinesis as the young
girl a cosmic entity known as the
Phoenix force discovered her seeking a
powerful host body to bind to and the
Phoenix force took over Jean when she
was an adult while she was on a mission
in space unleashing her power and
violent and evil ways and here we see
what looks like one of those Tantrums
the x-men confront her in this
neighborhood now in the first trailer we
learned that this is Red Hook New York
which I found interesting because that's
a town mentioned in the very first
episode of the x-men series Legion on FX
after what happened
I'd say that's an understatement this
mystery of the Red Hook incident never
really came up again in Legion
but maybe this nasty episode with
Phoenix is what they were all referring
to and we see how deadly this gets in
the next clip I'm not giving up on you
team she was my friend you're my family
James no matter what okay so this is
pretty wild as I speculated in my last
trailer breakdown misty Jennifer
Lawrence will die as a result of Jean
Grey's Phoenix force Simon Kinberg
actually confirmed this in an interview
but I'm curious how exactly my superior
characters don't die when they're just
blown back maybe she'll get impaled on
that American flag fly Paul aah
so yeah it's Mystique's funeral engraved
that we see in the other footage and
it's this tragedy that turns the x-men
against each other and divides them into
factions half wanting to kill Jean Grey
and the Phoenix force and half 180 to
protect her and I totally understand Kim
Berg's dramatic narrative reasons to
kill off Jennifer Lawrence's character
in this movie but why so is it right
away in this trailer I suppose yeah
trailers are getting more and more
spoilery these days especially when
psychos like me analyze the crap out of
them it's hard to keep leaks from
getting out but I have a theory that
maybe not all is what it seems in this
footage maybe there's some twist some
secret that's still being hidden from us
I haven't thought on that that I'll get
to later but before I move on I just got
a point out this detail of the Winnebago
Harvey this is said 1992 so I just love
this Spaceballs clunker showing up and
if you look behind it you can see a real
fantasy jet the x-men's blackbird on the
street behind it next clip
you're special gene and if you stop
fighting that force inside you
Foom Grayson okay this section shows us
Jessica Chastain's character now this
trailer was released to coincide with
Chastain's promo appearance on Jimmy
Fallon where I guess she was pretty
tight-lipped about her character but she
revealed a couple things you want to
move stuff with your mind right miss
Jean Grey has a power that I want a
harness for my own uses I get to beat up
a lot of x-men in the movies you do
maybe kill some but he's weird I can't
see anything yeah so we don't know
exactly who she is only that this
otherworldly antagonist has been
described in the past as a shapeshifter
and has been credited with the name
Smith Kinberg has described her as an
amalgam of a couple different characters
and iterations of characters over the
span of the different talents of the
Dark Phoenix story that have taken place
so that could mean Chastain Smith
whatever is lilandra empress of the
Shiar the Shiar is another alien empire
in the Marvel Comics along with the Kree
and the scroll and they're tied in with
the Phoenix war story they actually put
her on trial they try to depower the
Phoenix force so she could be lilandra
or maybe a little Andres sister death
bird but then there's that shapeshifter
description maybe that could point to
her being a scroll no I don't see this
movie wanted to step on Marvel's toes
with the way they're depicting the
scrolling Captain Marvel but when you
read into Kinberg and Chastain's
descriptions of this character it's just
big enough to open up another possible
theory maybe Chastain is a manifestation
of the Phoenix force itself like some
kind of presence living in genes mind
kind of like the shadow king with Legion
who's also one omega-level mutant by the
way notice how this character melts the
room around gene transforming it to this
smoky nebula that gives gene a glimpse
into the wider cosmos maybe she slipped
her son acid or maybe she's the Phoenix
force inside her mind opening her mind
to see beyond
so when Chastain says she gets to kill
some x-men maybe she was referring to
the idea that when gene goes full
Phoenix force she fuses with Chastain
and lets this older president take the
wheel like sophie Turner will shape
shift into Jessica Chastain and Chastain
is the one to do the killin and maybe
that name Smith is a working name used
as a nod to Agent Smith from the matrix
who uses with hosts in a similar way and
uses them to attack enemies
chew on that while we look closely at
this imagery of the space incident that
causes genes exposure to the Phoenix
force you could see them coming upon
this stranded Space Shuttle which
appears to be spinning off its axis
surrounded by some particles and nearby
there's this trippy looking purplish
orange space part so yeah I'm thinking
this is a Phoenix force and it lured
gene and the rest out here by attacking
this human space shuttle and we get to
see more of this in the next clip okay
here we see how the space part surges
through the space shuttle causes an
explosion with the x-men caught in the
blast and all of this Phoenix force
rushes into gene and go through this
frame by frame she straight up
disappears
that's just empty space in fuselage
usually I don't see gene where'd she go
maybe this temporary symbiosis with the
cosmic force popped her through a
wormhole or maybe plucked her out of
time so the two of them could get to
know each other I don't know it just
feels very 2001 both the Stanley Kubrick
movie and the 2000s Brett Ratner classic
and as we jump back to this Red Hook
tragedy with Charles Xavier and Scott
Summers looking shocked we move on once
again so cool
tell me how we fix this Charles tell me
what to do now don't never watch a jerk
okay after some of those funeral shots
we saw in the first trailer we see
Charles and Magneto in the x-mansion
which kind of feels similar to that seen
in the last stand with Charles and Jean
except instead of her killing Charles
here she's going after Erik Lehnsherr
with the room around them crumbling
apart now this is a huge feel that she
can f up his helmet like this because
Magneto's helmet is specifically
designed to block telepathic and
telekinetic powers but now Jean is
crushing it like that did it lid to
tried to squeeze this into a small I
just love this detail the pointed corner
of the helmet bending up toward his eye
I have to stab it as Nick Fury would
tell you loosen eyes what you get for
trusting someone again this might not be
Jean doing the question here in the
promo real released with Chastain's
appearance on Fallon you can see
Chastain's character standing beside her
watching intently as if the two are in
sync and with Charles in Scott in
cerebro here I could watch this intense
barking between James McAvoy enticed her
hit on Lou
tell me what to do now don't never watch
a turn tell me what to do and I don't
know what your turn tell me what to do I
don't know what to do well let's move on
what they don't understand they fear and
what they fear they seek to destroy
sure Oh Charles okay after Chastain's
character and Jean complete each other's
cliches we see the best thing to come
out of these recent x-men movies
Quicksilver Peter Maximoff if you look
behind him you can see this bishop power
truck which could be a nod to the x-men
mutant Bishop and we see this very cool
slow-motion attack as he hops across
exploded debris to try to reach Dean and
you can see the slightly bolt maybe this
is after she moved one of the storms
lightning attacks out of the way
and notice how among all this debris is
a solitary boot could this be one of the
boots that mystique was just wearing in
the previous shots holy SH did Jean Grey
blow his stick to bits but leave her
boots behind that would be awesome but
as I said before I think there could be
more to this scene that's being hidden
from us like the only reason I could see
the studio being justified with
revealing Mystique's death in this
moment is that if this scene also
featured another shocking death and both
Chastain and Kinberg have said multiple
x-men will die looking at all this
footage that we see from this movie I
don't see Evan Peters Quicksilver really
showing up in any of the other sequences
so what if both mystique and Quicksilver
die kind of like a walking dead Abraham
and Lynne Cabo deal look folks it's
probably the end of this version of the
x-men in the movies there's really
nothing stopping the studio from killing
all of these darlings so you know just
walk it off and move on
I'm scared when I lose control that deep
zap two people
the girl dies she's still June we can
still help her
okay here's some soldiers raid a crash
train car in the middle of the streets
that could be from the train sequence
that we see later
and then a quick shot of Charles
wheeling through the x-mansion which
looks messy and abandoned now it could
be possible that all the students have
fled out of fear jean grey this would
definitely not be the teacher anyone
wants for homeroom we see some shots of
Nightcrawler
and then shot a magneto saying that Jean
needs to die now behind magneto is a
newcomer this is confirmed to be Selene
who in the comics is sort of a psychic
vampire associated with the Hellfire
Club she can psionically drain your
lifeforce she shows up on the recently
released poster of the movie along with
another newcomer Kinberg hasn't
confirmed exactly who this is yet some
people think it's Red Lotus who's a
martial arts expert also so sued with
the Hellfire Club then there's this
interesting shot of gene floating in
space as the Phoenix force flows into
her and notice how it's repairing torn
pieces of her clothes skin tissue
seemingly empowering her maybe
reinforcing her to allow her to survive
in space and next there's a shot of the
x-men on this prison train car you can
see the cuffs on the walls there as Hank
leaps upper head and throws this dude
very cool on to the next clip sometimes
you want to believe people have
something that they are not
mother tell me knows who they are it's
too late okay here magneto activates
these machine guns in theses clips if
someone in heels none of the bullets
have any effect I'm assuming this is
Chastain's character again it could be
the Phoenix force having taken over
sophie Turner Jean Grey and is now
shape-shifted into the form of Chastain
I know it's kind of a crazy theory it's
just the actresses do look like they
could be sisters then the shot of storm
using lightning to zap a bunch of
soldiers off the strain Scott trying to
save Jane from space farts but this evil
look says it all
actually that dark shape deep in the
background behind Jean could be
Chastain's presence once again that is
if she's still wearing that black dress
if this is earth this would be more
evidence that her character is a
presence haunting genes mind and one of
those ghosts Najee at Hill House but now
let's move on to the final clip she's
coming
cool we got ourselves a train heist in
this case I steam the whole damn train
the x-men and Magneto's team are both
imprisoned by these guards look at the
printing on their uniforms and see you
awesome the x-men are being kidnapped
and sent over to Marvel Cinematic
Universe we got him boys no no no no the
MCU in this context is probably mutants
containment unit something like that it
also looks as though the mutants are
wearing those mutant inhibitor collars
similar to the ones in Deadpool 2 way to
wrestle wear them in the ice box oh I
guess Dark Phoenix is set in 1992 maybe
that could explain the different models
look here's my question for you guys I
don't imagine many of you have been
dying to see Dark Phoenix like we don't
mind that this movie exists but we're
kind of just like okay but there's still
a lot of talent behind this movie it
could still be really good and there's a
couple movies coming out in 2019 that I
feel fit in that category so of all the
arguably less anticipated comic with
movies coming this year which do you
think will be the biggest surprise hit
Dark Phoenix the New Mutants or Joker
commad Emily woods your thoughts follow
me on Twitter and Instagram I da boss
and subscribe to this channel hit
subscribe to our podcast where we listen
to podcasts thank you for watching and
see you next time when Dark Phoenix is
released tickets push back again to 2024
[Music]